you hear a lot now about pessimism  things like that and I think we should  sort of not been stupidly naively  optimistic I still believe that Europe  is a continent which has an enormous  potential a lot to offer and I think we  should encourage the young people to  grab their transition to do it and I  also think that the European Union in  the end is what you make out of it and  this is also for the people the citizens  they elect people they are part of it  it's actually quite open if you really  want to know what's going on it's  complicated but you can learn about it  the union will be what the people of  Europe will make out of it